Ridley Scott's sci-fi opus Blade Runner has
become known as one of the best, most influential
movies of all time.
One of the movie's best lines, however, didn't
come from screenwriters.
Rather, it came from the actor playing the
role: Rutger Hauer.
Hauer plays Roy, the leader of a band of "replicants"
— basically bioengineered androids created
for slave labor.
To prevent a full-on revolt, scientists give
replicants a limited four-year lifespan.
Roy spends the movie trying desperately to
find a "cure" for the design flaw dooming
him and his friends to short lives.
By the end of the film, he's given up hope,
and spares the Blade Runner, Deckard — played
by Harrison Ford — hired to kill him.
During a table read of the script, while reciting
his final monologue, Rutger Hauer added a
final coda:
"All those moments will be lost in time...like
tears in the rain."
The line was so-well received that it was
added to the script, and it has since become
one of the most quoted bits from the entire
movie.